recevons sur arte france daniel fertin
des secrétaire général adjoint fo
cheminots
ah bon vous remercie d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on est moins
des contrôles massifs ans qui avait été
annoncé quelle lecture en faites vous
depuis le début il ya plusieurs sujets
dans cette affaire mais depuis le début
nous on dit que c'est pas faisable tout
simplement parce que les contrôleurs de
la sncf ils sont pas payés à rien faire
s'ils voulaient ils ont déjà énormément
de tâches à accomplir
le contrôle des titres de transport ne
vient qu'après un certain nombre de
tâches qui concerne la sécurité des
circulations le service à bord etc et on
nous rajoute le contrôle d'un d'un
document en plus donc on savait que
c'était pas faisable à bord des trains à
l'accueil des trains la sncf depuis le
début c'est qu'on peut pas contrôler
l'ensemble des passagers
la preuve elle l a fait appel à des
sociétés privées pour faire un tri dans
les gares et mais pire que cela l'état à
la base qui prend ces mesures qui sont
des mesures de restriction des libertés
publiques pour contraindre les gens à se
vacciner faut le rappeler
l'état qui prend ces mesures c'est qu'il
n'est même pas lui même capable de les
mettre en oeuvre puisque sinon il aurait
mis des forces de l'ordre à l'entrée des
gares pour filtrer les arrivées
quatre cent mille voyageurs par jour
personne n'est en mesure de contrôler
il y a eu un retour en arrière on l'a vu
pour les centres commerciaux est ce que
cela pourrait être le cas - pour les
trains qui effectuent des trajets longue
distance
écoutez c'est pas à nous de le dire nous
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que depuis le
début on trouve que même par rapport au
texte de loi qui ont été adoptées les
mesures concrètes qui ont été choisis
par la suite ne correspondent pas aux
textes de loi ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que on adopte une loi qui impose
le pass sanitaires dans les trains inter
régionaux de longue distance
or le décret ne définit pas la longue
distance et l'imposture des trains qui
ne sont pas intéressés c'est à dire
qu'il ya certains tgv c'est dans une
seule région donc
nous on se doute bien que c'est pas une
mesure réaliste et de toute façon sur le
fond le pass sanitaires on le répète
nous on n'y est pas favorable c'est à
dire que depuis le début ce gouvernement
qui est incapable de gérer la pandémie
parce que il fait face à des pénuries de
moyens vu tout ce qui a été détruit ces
dernières années en termes de services
publics
et comme il n'est pas capable de gérer
il gère la pénurie est en jeu pour gérer
la pénurie met en oeuvre des mesures de
remise en cause des libertés et c'est
pas une solution est ce que vous êtes
secrétaire général adjoint de fo
cheminots est ce que il y à des
négociations des discussions qui sont en
cours avec la direction de la sncf
assure le contrôle et des voyageurs
n'ont de toute façon c'est une mesure
légale gouvernementale se s'est pas
c'est pas en interne dans l'entreprise
que ça peut se discuter mais après
l'état prend des mesures est la vraie
question c'est est-ce que ces mesures
sont applicables
et pour notre part on pense qu'elles ne
sont pas vraiment donc depuis le début
la sncf dit qu'elle va faire des
contrôles aléatoires c'est ce qu'elle
fait mais contrôles aléatoires c'est
comment comme leurs noms l'indiquent
elles sont aléatoires
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec mon
daniel fierté je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général adjoint de fo
cheminots merci